[Applause]
every once in a while an idea comes
around that disrupts everything the
printing press the light bulb this ass
and now this what if we told you you you
you that we could eradicate inequality
poverty and general douchiness in a
matter of seconds we bring to you white
hats do something racist your ass will
get taxed we will take away one thing
related to the group or groups you
offended white tax while sitting on the
bus Doris Roberts white American reaches
forward to braid Jasmine Jordans hair
without permission suddenly every black
female artist is erased from her iTunes
including Beyonce her strut her life her
sex forever offbeat six members of kuma
Kubik Epsilon fraternity dress in
sombreros and put fake mustaches on
their faces as they drink margaritas and
eat tacos we will construct a wall
around the frat house not letting in
erase his amount white X Jared Spaulding
white American calls the police on his
neighbor Jack Newman for entering his
own home
Jared's artistic and food taste is
eradicated he spends his remaining days
watching Blue Bloods and eating white
bread white acts
James Powell pulls at the skin of his
face to make slanty eyes and speaks in a
made-up language he credits this Chinese
white people may have invented racism if
they are not the only ones guilty of it
James must now use carrier pigeons to
send pics and pinecones to wipe his ass
you make fun of people you don't get to
use their inventions right Tex
Josh hunter white American claims
reverse racism for not making his
basketball team the consequence reverse
slavery
Josh hunters a slave
[Music]
my tux if these behaviors continue we
will begin to take the things y'all made
away car and walking based sports NPR
ABBA podcasts and miniseries about one
can wrongly accused white person who we
all know federal penitentiaries are
filled with thousands of black and brown
people who get in trouble for doing
white people do all the time
vegan mayonnaise finding yourself Jeff
Goldblum
yeah Jeff Goldblum yeah we want his fine
ass so shape up or get your taken why
that's
[Applause]
[Music]